we know that as much as we have now the
reign of King Charles and queen consort
Camilla the future
is William and Kate and their children
as well and we could not get enough of
those precious children
especially Charlotte seemingly always
putting George in his place in public
yes but truth be told there is an heir
and there is a spare there is and I I
you know and and people sort of think
it's very disparaging to have this idea
of Despair and and um it is a historic
concept we've always had to have a spare
to support the air but I think people
should think about it perhaps in a more
modern context and I think you're seeing
a support act here I think in the same
way that Charles has always been very
heavily supported by his sister the
Princess Anne we're now seeing even from
a very early age in his life Prince
George supported by Princess Charlotte
there's a wonderful Dynamic there and
you know they were together at the
service of Thanksgiving for Prince
Philip and you know they they've sort of
stepped in on some high profile roles
when it came to Prince George carrying
out his first official engagement which
was to Cardiff over the Jubilee weekends
the William cake decided to include
Charlotte on that so in the same way
that William always had his wingman in
in Harry I think it's rather wonderful
that that is being echoed here with
George and Charlotte you know you're
going to see I think real teamwork at
place here so cool and I feel like we
can already see it in the works you know
what about Louis How would how does he
fit into the airport well Lewis I mean
Louie's role is going to be interesting
and I was told that the the cambridges
or the Wales is as they are now really
looked to the westics's Edward and
Sophie and how they're raising their
children as a sort of something of of a
template because actually they are royal
children and they have titles and yet
they live remarkably ordinary lives and
Lady Louise Windsor had a job in a
gardening center over the summer school
holidays she's going to go to university
actually following Prince Williamson
Andrews they're living relatively
ordinary lives now of course the Wales
children are different Prince George is
an heir right we know he's aware of
being an air who his father is who he
will one day be and so it is different
but I think that move to Windsor that
they recently did which was a bold move
taking the children out of a school that
they were very happy in moving them to
Windsor so that they can have this sort
of
I think a life more out of the spotlight
Kensington Palace is very overlooked
London is it it's an Highway storm right
it is and I think they can have a
different life in Windsor so that these
children are able to sort of live as
ordinary lives as Royal children
possibly can because at some point they
will take on Royal duties they already
are and I think we're going to see I
think we are going to see more of that I
mean it wouldn't surprise me well I've
traveled to New Zealand with the Royal
children to Canada and I think we will
see the Wales is including their
children where they can where it's not
disrupted to the school routine because
again that image of the future is a
really powerful one but Winters have
become like official Royal duties not
for me I think it won't be for many
years and I think you know for William
particularly who was able to enjoy a
very rewarding military career served
with the RAF and then went on to have a
civilian job as a as a search and rescue
pilot he's had the advantage of being
able to have that he's going to want the
same for his children too and and I
think just it's also a probably a moment
to raise the fact that you know William
never wanted to LeapFrog his father he
wants this time to be the Prince of
Wales for which there is no job
description for which he's going to
carve out his own identity whilst
raising this young family these are
precious and important years for him and
he he doesn't want to lose those years
[Music]